avant tout je tiens à remercier mes
homologues
le président azerbaïdjanais et le
premier ministre arménien d'être venu
aujourd'hui à moscou pour se rencontrer
afin de discuter des questions liées à
l'exécution des accords de paix du 9
novembre dernier
nous sommes parvenus à la conclusion que
les conditions de cet accord dans
l'ensemble sont respectées on ne note
pas d'incidents particuliers
le groupe de maintien de la paix russes
sur place sur le terrain effectué ses
missions et comme je l'aï dit au début
de notre réunion aujourd'hui il ya plus
de 40000 personnes déplacées le travail
de restauration des infrastructures des
infrastructures énergique en matière
d'énergie sur le plan social sont en
cours et ces discussions était utile
puisque nous avons pu nous mettre
d'accord et nous avons signé une
déclaration commune sur l'évolution de
la situation dans la région en
l'occurrence il s'agit de pas concrets
en matière d'établissement des relations
économiques de des fusions de
développement des projets
d'infrastructures et un groupe de coûts
de travail votre tête va être mise en
place entre les trois pays au niveau des
premiers ministres arménie azerbaïdjan
et en russie et il mettre en place très
prochainement des sous groupes de
travail au niveau des experts pour le
développement des infrastructures et de
l'économie de la région
je suis convaincu que la mise en oeuvre
de ces accords fera du bien tant pour
l'azerbaïdjan que pour l'arménie est
sans aucun doute cela apportera à
il va en faveur de l'ensemble de la
développement de la région monsieur
poutine
tout d'abord je tiens à vous remercier
pour votre invitation et l'initiative
d'organiser cette réunion
j'estime aussi que cette réunion est
très importante pour assurer le
développement sécurisé et durable de
notre région
deux mois écoulés depuis l'accord du
cessez-le-feu et le fait qu'aujourd'hui
les dirigeants des 3 ap signataires se
sont réunis aujourd'hui à mouscou
signifie que si nous cherchons à dresser
le bilan des activités qui ont lieu en
septembre octobre et la déclaration
signée aujourd'hui montre quelles sont
nos intentions parce que en des
paragraphes été le déblocage des
infrastructures de transport ce domaine
est essentiel pour le développement de
la région et contribuer à renforcer la
sécurité parce que le développement des
infrastructures des transports et dans
l'intérêt des peuples la russie
l'azerbaïdjan l'arménie les pays voisins
je suis sûr que les pays voisins
participons au développement du réseau
des infrastructures de transport dans
notre région nous devons chercher à
trouver les deux mêmes dans lequel on
peut avancer
la déclaration commune du 9 novembre ou
du 10 novembre lors de bakou est bien
mise en oeuvre la plupart des points ont
été déjà exécutées
la mission du maintien de la paix
accomplis bien sa mission et il n'y
avait pas de grandes préoccupations sauf
quelques incidents mineurs et qu'on vous
avait dit à monsieur poutine
le conflit dans leur haut karabakh reste
dans le passé il faut penser à l'avenir
notre avenir comment comment vivre
ensemble comment débloquer les
infrastructures de transport et
renforcer la stabilité régionale et la
sécurité dans la région
je vous remercie monsieur poutine et
j'estime que cette réunion était très
fructueuse merci cher monsieur poutine
avant tout je tiens à vous remercier
pour les efforts que vous faites pour le
rétablissement de la sécurité de la paix
dans notre région et pour le règlement
du conflit du haut karabagh
malheureusement ce conflit n'est pas
encore réglé puisque et dit encore des
questions
certes nous avons pu établir le cessez
le feu mais il reste encore des
questions que nous devons résoudre et
certaines de ces questions c'est celle
du statut du haut karabakh et bien
entendu l'arménie est prête à poursuivre
les négociations dans le cadre de la
coprésidence du groupe de minsk de
l'osce et eux en particulier sur cette
question
et malheureusement aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas réussi à résoudre
la question des prisonniers de guerre et
c'est le point le plus sensible dans la
question dans cette question humanitaire
et nous allons donc poursuivre comme
nous sommes comme nous sommes convenus
nous allons poursuivre nos efforts dans
cette direction et nous considérons en
particulier que le huitième point de
notre déclaration commune n'est pas mise
en oeuvre complètement et j'espère que
nous parviendrons très prochainement à
une solution concrète et je dois dire
que la déclaration que nous avons signé
aujourd'hui est effectivement importante
et je ne le cache pas la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord stipulait dans cette
déclaration peut modifier l'image
économique de notre région et les
innovations économiques peuvent aussi
constituer un gage plus sûr de sécurité
et bien entendu nous sommes prêts à
travailler de façon constructive dans
cette direction mais comme je les dis
malheureusement en une seule réunion ce
n'est pas possible de résoudre toutes
les questions et j'espère que nous
allons poursuivre ses travaux dans cette
direction et je souligne encore une fois
que pour nous la question la plus
sensible est une question d'ordre
humanitaire
c'est la question des changes des
prisonniers qui a été prévu dans le
point 8 de notre déclaration commune du
des 9 et 10 novembre je vous remercie
encore une fois je remercie mes
homologues pour le travail constructif
d'aujourd'hui